c'est aujourd'hui que le premier
ministre edouard philippe s'est exprimé
sur les détails du déconfinement dates
des vacances réouverture des restaurants
le gouvernement a tenté de concilier
santé publique et soutien envers les
acteurs du tourisme
c'est officiel après avoir longtemps
conseillé d'attendre le premier ministre
encourage enfin les français a réservé
leurs vacances des vacances en france
qui le promet seront intégralement
remboursés si une recrudescence des cas
de covile 19 dans l'hexagone forcer le
gouvernement à reconfirmer du côté des
restaurants edouard philippe n'a pas
encore donné de date définitive mais a
promis que le gouvernement trancherait
dans dix jours si l'épidémie est
contenue d'ici cette date ils pourront
ouvrir rapidement pour ceux qui sont
dans les départements vers une
réouverture le 2 juin pour être
envisagée si l'évolution de l'épidémie
ne se dégrade pas le premier ministre a
également annoncé un fonds de 18
milliards d'euros pour venir en aide aux
acteurs du tourisme et de la
restauration ainsi qu'un accès étendu au
fonds de solidarité et au chômage
partiel
[Musique]
j'ai encore rien écouté je suis issu de
la musique quoi alors
bernard sabbah est avec nous merci
bernard sabbah bonsoir merci je vois que
vous en tout cas pour l'instant pas de
coiffeur ni par j mais ça vous va très
très bien
le cheveu est fou voilà et on aime voix
la liste au tourisme aujourd'hui alors
quel pays
là vous avez besoin d'un paris angoulême
tout de suite il vous le sort les cils
et merci d'être avec nous il est chaude
chaque matin en direct avec julien
courbet bien sûr sur rtl de 9h30 à 11h30
ça cartonne pour julien et pourtant il
part de très bas parce que je sais que
de 9h15 à 9 heures contre ça marche
papier la pauvreté abel twitter donc je
sais qu'ils rament après pourvoi la
remontée les autres
il a dit qu'on allait avoir des vacances
edouard philippe est-ce qu'il faut
rester en france bernard sabbah est ce
qu'on va pouvoir partir à l'étranger
est-ce que aussi des personnes
étrangères vont pouvoir venir passer des
vacances en france
est-ce que valérie benaïm va pouvoir
partir pour le grand concours de
t-shirts mouillés à djerba la douce
on a besoin de savoir où on a besoin de
réponses alors franchement juillet août
je pense qu'on va pouvoir partir en
france
et puis aussi sur les dom-tom ça veut
dire qu'on va pouvoir faire un pari
marque pointe à pitre c'est quand même
une bonne chose fort de connaît un petit
peu on n'est pas très nuls ont joué
paris - bastien alain vigneault donc on
va voir partir comme un petit peu plus
loin mais on va être donc en france
c'est important de le signaler
et peut-être que les frontières vont
s'ouvrir parce que vous savez qu'on est
dans les espaces schengen ya pas de
frontières et pour l'instant il n'y a
que l'aspect frontaliers ça veut dire
peut-être entre la belgique et la france
on va pouvoir bouger un petit peu
peut-être entre la france et l'italie
ça dépendra évidemment des conditions
sanitaires alors donc on va pouvoir vous
pensez on va pouvoir faire je pense que
la plupart des gens vont partir en
france que vous avez déjà des échos sur
les hôtels ce qui pourrait ouvrir oui je
pense que le fait d'avoir déjà ouvert
les plages en zone verte ça veut dire
que dans tous les cas les grands groupes
hôteliers vont pouvoir ouvrir dès le 2
juin et partir et donc on va pouvoir
partir donc dès le mois de juillet dans
des séjours justement sympa en bord de
mer mais aussi à la montagne ne faut pas
oublier qu'on peut partir à la montagne
est de très très belles perspectives
sérieuses auxquelles on ne pense pas
l'été mais l'avantagé d'entrée aux 500
gagne rien à vous dire quelque chose sur
les vacances juste une question vous est
posée à la sueur c'est bernard sabbah
spécialistes le tout bien entendu que il
y avait des organismes de tourisme
justement qui se portait garant si par
malheur ça y avait un souci qui advenait
et qu'on ne puisse plus est parce que la
edouard philippe a dit vous pouvez y
aller pouvait commencer dans l'ain déjà
réservé mais apparemment les organismes
de tourisme 10 vous inquiétez pas
réservé parce que si par malheur il ya
un souci on vous remboursera alors c'est
exactement ça rassure alors voilà
comment se passe il ya une ordonnance du
26 mars où le premier ministre avait dit
qu'il a fait sien dame tous les accords
que vous avez passé tous les acomptes
versés tous les soldes que vous avez
versé pour le voyage vous avez un à voir
et vous l'utilisez dans les 18 mois ça
c'était la première règle là les choses
ont changé le premier ministre dit à
chaud suivante cyril il a dit voilà vous
pouvez réserver vous n'avez aucun risque
parce que en tout cas on vous rembourse
aux alors moindre à contre 100% donc ça
l'or valait les ménages réservé à trois
semaines de la khadra elle va se faire
rembourser mes scènes dansées les gars
je pense que ce sera difficile de partir
de dakar acd terrain c'est à dire qu'on
aura pas d avoir exactement sur un
remboursement c'est l'engagement
correctionnelle ça c'est ça c'est très
très important qui est assez simple oui
a alors il parait que les plages sont
ouverts mais qu'on a le droit de marcher
mais pas de s'asseoir vraiment sur une
place ça va pour l'instant jusqu'au 2
juin on contrôle justement cette
épidémie on demande aux gens d'être
mobile ça alors c'est que quand on est
en plein air généralement par rapport à
l'eau on n'a pas de soucis de corps
d'aviation au moment où on parle mais je
ne suis pas médecin je n'ai pas de boule
de cristal mais sachez dans tous les cas
que jusqu'au 2 juin
on marche sur la plage ne s'arrête pas
d'accord on marche sur la plage le
premier qui s'arrête
il prend du sable dans la gueule
boulette de se baigner
pour l'instant on ne peut pas se baigner
on peut faire du sport dans l'eau mais
on ne se baigne est-ce qu'on peut vendre
des beignets sur la page
[Rires]
pas de sortie alors bernard est ce que
il ya des personnes en revanche qu'ils
vont pouvoir venir passer leurs vacances
en france
c'est très compliqué et cyril pour
l'instant on a neuf millions de français
qui habituellement partent à l'étranger
la corse et 9 union cholet gardez donc
ça c'est la première règle deuxièmement
il ya 17 millions de gens entre juillet
et août qui viennent chez nous et j'ai
bien peur franchement qu on ne le sait
pas donc il ya un pacte de sécurité
après mme de caméras thermiques pour les
aéroports il ya des contrôles sanitaires
et pour l'instant l'europe s'est réuni à
deux jours l'europe n'a fait que des
recommandations non condamnation en
disant on va écouter essayer de nous de
vous arranger mais c'est très très
compliqué pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
règle et a toujours eu ou à l'espace
schengen et d'emballer ce match mais
carrément à bruxelles cfm a bar mitzvah
la lessive alors y'a un sondage qui est
sorti aujourd'hui au tour des français
et des vacances et on apprend que
l'attention des français étaient
bouleversés par coronavirus bas bien
entendu
51% des français ne veulent pas partir
en vacances + 20 % par rapport à l'année
dernière
21% des français n'ont pas de projets
pour cet été et 76% des français veulent
voyager locale donc autant dire ça va
faire du bien quand même à toul et les
voilà à tous les hôtels français à tous
les bars à tous les restaurants parce
qu'il a fait d'autres annonces
edouard philippe regardez il a annoncé
la réouverture des bars et restaurants
regarder pour quelle date et valérie
benaïm je vous inviterai à l'occasion
c'est vrai oui bien sûr c'est qu'en
l'occasion à l'occasion c'est dexia va
rouvrir d'accord un scénographe launches
et nous si on paye on peut venir
non on regarde pour les cafés
restaurants
la date de réouverture sera fixée
au cours de la semaine du 25 mai pour
ceux qui sont dans les départements vers
une réouverture le 2 juin pourrait être
envisagé si l'évolution de l'épidémie ne
se dégradent pas et sous réserve que les
mesures sanitaires qui sont recommandées
par le haut conseil de la santé publique
soient parfaitement respectée je veux le
dire clairement dans les départements
qui vont rester envers notre objectif
c'est de faire en sorte que les cafés et
la restauration puisse ouvrir dès le 2
jours le 2 juin
voilà bernard sabbah ça va faire du bien
tout ça oui déjà il faut savoir que 50
cent le chiffre d'affaires pour ces gens
là se font entre juillet et août dans la
sueur jeu sont énormes on parle c'est 7%
du pib le touriste donc c'est pas anodin
comme comme des marchés c'est quand même
beaucoup d'emplois on a cinquante mille
emplois dans les agences de voyages qui
sont en difficulté aujourd'hui nationale
sont accompagnés par le gouvernement
parce qu on a décalé justement le
chômage partiel jusqu'à fin septembre
vous voyez quand même que les efforts
ont été faits par le gouvernement ils
ont mis 18 milliards sur la table et un
milliard trois pour accompagner avec
savez les prêts garantis par l'état
est ce que vous sentez un engouement
pour le sud de la france là ou pas il ya
beaucoup de gens du nord qui vont aller
dans le sud ou bien un projet qu'on va
aller aussi dans le golfe du morbihan
valeur en bretagne on va aller en bord
de mer un petit peu partout et puis pour
nous il de frost connaissant ne sais pas
si on ne peut dépasser ces fameuses 100
km en attend justement le jeu ça les
vaut lui exactement alors regardez ya
une question twitter ce qu'on est en
direct bien entendu c'est christelle du
quart à 147 qui me dit et quand on a nos
vacances me joins on fait comment
bernard sabbah assez compliqué je
reconnais que si elle est là tu as beau
fixe et les règles nationales sur un
tout petit peu le 2 juin
tout va se déclencher à ce moment là et
puis évidemment si elles avaient déjà
réservé depuis un petit bouton l1 non
qu'elle aura ce fan ou à voir qu'on a
évoqué thaler et s'ils réservent un nom
est bond lui remboursera si on est
bloqué avec ce coronavirus ce
déborderait trop même question
d'élégance à céret à christelle de
prendre mi septembre jusqu'à mi juin
en revanche la nouvelle d'aujourd'hui
moi ça a été ma nouvelle la bonne
nouvelle de la journée la réouverture
des histoires des restaurants dans les
zones vertes ça a été ma bonne nouvelle
la nouvelle que les français vont
pouvoir éventuellement peut-être partir
en vacances ça a été ma bonne nouvelle
heure tu disais dans le sud
ça va peut être que dans de suite ça va
être par le nord pour la simple et bonne
raison que si metz bêtise un bernard
lenoir tugal l'espagne et l'italie
il ya une quatorzaine qui est mise en
place la balle
si tu veux partir en espagne il faut que
tu arrives en espagne tu as 14 juillet
s'est enfermée ça veut dire au monde un
mois de vacances et après au bout du
quatorzième jour vous êtes en dehors
après vous revenez ici encore c'est au
bras long pour être confrères mois et
demi et deux mois de vacances on va voir
tout de suite une autre question
twitter les chéris merci je m'en fous
des vacances en france ou dans les
dom-tom je veux savoir si on peut se
barrer au bled maroc algérie ou non ça
me saoule de rester en france j'ai envie
de voir ma famille et mes amis du maroc
et de l'algérie on embrasse l'algérie et
le maroc
bien sûr c'est inès match qui nous
envoie ça bien sûr c'est le pseudo de
valérie bénaïm tout le monde y compris
alors c'est pas possible c'est compliqué
je voulais mais tu as beau fixe des
règles aucune garantie dans tous les cas
et puis vous savez quel et compagnie
sont en difficulté il faut pas oublier
que les compagnies aériennes sont en
très grosse difficultés
on va voir peu près 25 millions de gens
qui vont disparaître dans le métier de
l'aérés ans avec les aéroports tous les
métiers ce qu'on appelle cette élite
vont disparaître pourquoi parce que
c'est compliqué aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de compagnies qui perdent
évidemment beaucoup d'argent savait que
air france d'être consolidé à hauteur de
7 milliards par l'état
3 milliards donnés par les pays bas par
rapport à calais puisque ça va faire
représenter une enveloppe de 10
milliards d'euros
julien pardon je ne sais pas trop c'est
patrick oui et c'est vrai que là
aujourd'hui on demande des contrats
garantis les côtés garantie c'est d'être
sur la compagnie fonctionnera encore
vous savantes et du juste avoué richard
nom antoine 30 secondes important
aujourd'hui les avions les propriétaires
tourner des avions le souci c'est qu'ils
sont s'ils ne sont pas pro b terre les
avions
ils sont en insécurité ça veut dire qu
ils vont être obligés de rendre aux
leasers l'appareil en question et là
malheureusement ils vont déposer le
bilan
donc alors que si on les propriétaires
de ces avions c'est le cas de grandes
compagnies aériennes je vais pas les
citer
elles ont leur avion ils ont l'appui de
l'état elles vont pouvoir s'en sortir
voilà la réalité le marché va
complètement changer si bernard ça va
vous ai vu ce qu'il a à dire c'est
compliqué toute façon tu as beau fixe et
les règles au final c'est compliqué 2
non merci
jean michel maire ces deux minutes les
décors deux c'est plus une question pour
vous par don berna plus mieux sont pour
vous cyril vous devez le ça est ce que
les yachts de plus de 35 mètres pour
sortir du chaos
dégagé dégagé
on n'est pas sur rtl un frère on les
évite les jeux de mots de ce genre on a
les élus qu'on a enfin dit que c'est un
public captif le public oui deux minutes
y'a raymond cayla c'est un élégant
possible qu'ils aient une flambée des
prix par rapport à la demande
c'est toujours le retrait la demande est
ce que les français doivent s'inquiéter
de la flambée des prix pour les
destinations des vacances maintenant que
le ministre a annoncé qu on pouvait
partir en vacances à ce tour ce qu'on
doit ce jeu sont derrière des
réservations ou est ce qu'on doit
attendre
alors d'abord il faut pas attendre il
faut se jeter sur les relations mais
j'espère que les acteurs du tourisme aux
micros ne marche pas
mon chrono marche pas bon bah tant pis
on annule la question c'est une question
rom et redonne la question des primes et
la question à 10 microns marchand
fedasil a dès sa version 2 à avoir peur
du zanu chanter quoi j'ai mon bout de
mes rêves jouer alors flambée des prix
dudu du tourisme en fait vu qu'il va y
avoir l'offre et la demande
il va y avoir beaucoup de demandes et
les gens vont rester en france
est-ce que ça à faire flamber les prix
est ce que d'aller en bretagne ça va
coûter deux fois plus cher que la
normale
je vais vous dire ça sera la faute des
acteurs du tourisme et ça veut dire que
ça serait une politique à court terme et
c'est une erreur il court termisme
permettre aux gens de partir aujourd'hui
vous avez des grands groupes qui font
des offres vraiment en vous disant
réserver pour zéro euro vous ne risquez
rien auprès des petites assurera selon
vous on sera tous n'envoyer que le jeune
allemand ces gens là ne sont pas
suicidaires faut pas faire des vraiment
à court terme des raisonnements court
terme et j'ai bu donc pour résumer son
ça va être compliqué à avons fixé les
règles sont finale s'est appliqué non
soyez prudent mais c'est vrai c'est pas
de moi c'est à dire oui une dernière
question une dernière question juste
parce que vous avez évoqué les
compagnies qui pouvaient carrément
perdre lance avions leur flotte est ce
que ça veut dire que si on réserve sur
une compagnie et qu'on paye un billet
d'avion
ben si la compagnie elle disparaît aussi
l'avion disparaît ah bon
excusez moi mais c'est la meilleure
question non vous lira c'est important
de le dire parce que c'est que vous êtes
marocain attention c'est important pour
elle il n'y a pas de caisse de garantie
aujourd'hui pour les compagnies
aériennes nous acheter des billets
d'avion comme c'est le cas pour les
avoir en question si la compagnie
aérienne est défaillante personne ne
peut vous rembourser les biens avion ça
veut dire vous perdez votre argent alors
si vous achetez un forfait avec une
agence de voyage un acteur du tourisme
là vous êtes garantie et ça c'est
important parce qu'à une caisse de
garantie qui s'appelle la pst et ça c
est faux de dire aux téléspectateurs
prenez des forfaits avion + hôtel est un
avion + location d'arthur tourisme il en
sera remboursé et leur sort n'en sera